So, rolling. Rolling is the name for the motion around the longitudinal axis — it looks roughly like this. It also arises during turn flight of course, but also when entering a thermal from the side the wing can be knocked out of its axis and start rolling around the longitudinal axis, and that's something we want to prevent — that is, we want to stabilise the wing back over our head.
So that you can picture the whole thing, I quickly made this sketch. We have our starting point and we draw an imaginary line, and around this line we keep realigning the wing every time we've put it into roll — with the brake — far enough so that it ends up flying back onto this imaginary line.
That would be the goal.
Now what's important when rolling: body input, brake — and the body always comes first and the brake later.
Try not to pull the brake too fast either, but have a certain dynamic in the brake input — that is: weight, wait for the brake, then pull the brake, then a bit more up to the chest, and then release.
Now what's important when rolling is body input, brake, and the body always comes first and the brake later in the dynamic — that is: weight, wait for the brake, then pull the brake, then a bit more up to the chest, and then release.
It's a certain dynamic: weight onto the new side, wait, pull the brake, a bit more up to the chest, and release again.
That would be what's called a dynamic brake application.
Now, when does the change come? That's always the question where many pilots and students get stuck.
We begin rolling to the left — that is, we align the wing to the left, the pilot swings out to the right.
We align the wing to the left, the pilot swings out to the right.
Now, when the pilot is at the highest point, the change to the new side already comes — that is, lean the weight onto the right side, so we don't yet have to work with the right brake if possible, and the wing is already aligned a bit onto the new side.
Then, just like with pitching, especially at the beginning during the first three to four rollers, always wait until we've swung past underneath the wing.
And shortly after the lowest dead point — not as long as with pitching, but really briefly wait.
Wait a little after we've gone through the bottom, and then the brake comes — sorry — for the new side.
Exactly there wait again, bang, until we've arrived at the bottom, just very briefly past, and then the new side comes.
So really shortly after the lowest dead point, pull the brake. Let me count it through quickly again — that is: hang the weight in, then pull the brake, up to the chest, pull it dynamically, bang, up, and weight onto the new side.
And now wait.
Once we've swung past the bottom, immediately after, pull the brake, somewhat dynamically up to the
chest, and change again, bang, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, pull brake, dynamically
pull and change, bang, wait, wait, wait, wait, pull brake, dynamically pull
and change. Exit, very easy: once we've done the last roller,
right, bang, hand up, sit body-neutral, leave both hands up, wait
until we've swung up, and now the wing comes back from behind to the front, that
is, there we just have to catch it with both brakes and then slowly release both brakes
again — that is, wait until the wing passes over us, a bit
forward, then pull both brakes, perhaps also slightly asymmetrically, it doesn't
really matter, and then wait and slowly release. What you can also do — that would be
the second exit: you go through the last roller, bang,
pull the right brake, pull the left along with it, and go braked on both sides
out of the whole thing. So simply wait until you've swung
underneath and then slowly release. Actually very, very simple
in the explanation, but it needs good timing — when does the body come over, how extremely
can you also throw the body over quickly, and when does the brake come along. Here too, start
more slowly at the beginning, we build up with each time
more — I'll then say, pull a bit more or a bit more powerfully. Often
you also pull the brake a bit too short or one side more than the other,
so it's really important at the start, both sides evenly, both sides at the same
time and the intensity of the brake also has to be evenly the same on both sides.
If we're for example a bit too high, we do the roller to the
left side a bit too high, then it can happen that the outer wing collapses on us. If that
happens — nothing happens. We do the roller to the left side a bit too high, then it can happen that the outer wing collapses on us — if that happens, nothing happens.
We do the roller to the left side a bit too high, then it can happen that the outer wing collapses on us — if that happens, nothing happens.
For the rolling manoeuvre a prescribed flight axis is taken up.
Through measured, alternating pulling and releasing
of the left and right brake line, a rhythmic swinging around the
longitudinal axis occurs.
Caution!
Too strong braking or wrong intervals can lead to dangerous flight states.
Once you've established a regular roll, smaller steering impulses are enough to maintain the oscillations up to the correct angle.
To exit the manoeuvre, a single steering impulse is skipped, and then the last roll of the wing is caught with a brake impulse and subsequent measured release of the brake lines.